>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington DC.
>> Joan Weeks: Good afternoon
ladies and gentlemen.
On behalf of all my colleagues and
in particular Dr. Mary Jane Dy,
chief of the African and
Middle East division,
I'd like to extend a very
warm welcome to everybody.
I'm Joan Weeks, head of the Near
East Section, today's sponsor
of the program, The Double Life of
the First Syrian Immigrant Family.
This sounds very intriguing and our
speaker today is Dr. Linda Jacobs.
Before I start today's
program however
and Muhannad introduces our speaker,
I'd like to give you a brief
overview of our division
and its resources in the
hopes that you'll come back
and use our collections and this
reading room for your research.
This is a custodial division
comprised of three sections
that build and serve the collections
to researchers from
around the world.
We cover 75 countries and
over two dozen languages.
The Africa section includes all
of Sub-Sahara Africa, the Judaic
or Hebraic sections
covers Judaica worldwide
and the Near East section covers all
the Arab countries including North
Africa, Turkey, Turk and
Central Asia, Iran, Afghanistan,
the Muslims in Western
China, Russia and the Balkans
and the peoples of the Caucasus.
After today's program I'd
like to invite you to fill
in the little public events survey
that we've left in your chairs.
It helps us plan programs
for the future.
In addition, I'd like to promote and
talk about our new four corners blog
that has some wonderful specials -
blog post by our specialists here
and also in the Hispanic,
European and Asian divisions
and the URL is at the top.
So without further ado, though,
I'd like to call Dr. Muhannad Salhi
to the podium to introduce
our speaker for today.
Thanks you.
[ Clapping ]
>> Muhannad Salhi: Good
afternoon everybody.
Thank you all for joining us.
Our speaker today, Linda Jacobs has
a Ph D in Near Eastern archaeology
and anthropology from
the University of Oregon.
Her dissertation was on the second
millennium settlement patterns
of Iran.
She has spent much of her
professional life working
in economic development
projects in the MENA,
Middle East and North Africa region.
Jacobs has worked with the Near
East foundation for ten years
and continues to serve on its board,
as well as serving on the board
of the American University of
Beirut for three years and the board
of the Polytechnic, now
the Tandon school at NYU.
Today she will be speaking about her
second book "Strangers in the West."
And after the lecture there
will be a book signing event
for anyone who's interested
in purchasing the book.
Just a word to the audience,
this event is being videotaped
for subsequent broadcast on the
library website and other media.
The audience is encouraged
to offer comments
and raise questions during the
formal question and answer period,
but please be advised that your
voice and image may be recorded
and later broadcast
as part of this event.
By participating in the question
and answer period you are consenting
to the library's possible
reproduction
and transmission of your remarks.
Now, without further
ado Dr. Linda Jacobs.
[ Clapping ]
>> Linda Jacobs: Thank you so much.
Thank you to the division and
the library for having me.
It's really marvelous,
really wonderful.
As Muhannad said, I
have written a book
about the 19th century Syrian
colony in New York City,
which is in the back there.
And since that book was
published last fall I've been kind
of going off in many different
directions exploring some
of the people that I didn't have a
chance to do justice to in the book.
And the Arbeely family are one of
the most important of those groups.
They are indeed the first
Syrian immigrant family
to come to the United States.
They called themselves the
first Syrian immigrant family,
but people always try to
say that they are maybe not,
maybe there were other Syrians
before them, but indeed they were,
in fact, the first Syrian family
to come to the United States.
And the story of the Joseph Arbeely
family tells us how they constructed
an Arab-American identity, in fact,
the first Arab-American identity
of course in the United States,
since they were the
first Syrian family.
They constructed a double
identity and that looked both east
and west [inaudible]
like and keeping both
of those identities separate, but
- and mesmerizing their audiences,
both in life and on the stage.
They were both Oriental and
American at the same time.
I want to say.
first before I begin, that these
photographs have never been seen
by anyone in the world before, so
you'll all have a special treat.
The performance photographs are
from the National Anthropological
Archives
of the Smithsonian Institution
hidden deep away in the archives
and the family photographs are
from a collateral descendant
of the Arbeelys' who found me on
Facebook and who live in Texas now.
Habeeb Arbeely and his
daughter Dania Arbeely.
Okay. Yosef Aweth Hannah Alcolush
[sp] was born in the village
of Erbil about five miles outside of
Damascus in 1828 and he was educated
at the Damascus Orthodox College
and became a teacher there,
married in Damascus, had his
first three children in Damascus.
In 1860 he moved his family of three
children and his wife to Beirut.
Some say it was because of the
sectarian violence that was going
on in Syria, in Greater
Syria at that time.
Some say it was because he
saw opportunities in Beirut
that he had not had in Damascus.
In any case he took his children
to Beirut in 1860, set up a school
for the exiles of Orthodox
Damascenes there,
and was said to have collaborated
with Cornelius Van Dyck,
one of the founders of the Syrian
Protestant College in Beirut
to translate the Bible into Arabic.
So he had contact very early
on with American missionaries
and the Syrian Protestant College.
His oldest son Abraham, who's on
the left standing up in the left
of the picture took a medical
degree at Syrian Protestant College
in 1872, and then went on to
get a second medical degree
in Constantinople.
Later his third son, Felala,
also in the picture standing
up on the second from the
right, took a BA at SPC in 1872
and then a medical degree in 1876.
In 1878 Yosef decided that his
family was coming to America.
No one from Syria that he knew
or anyone knew had ever been
to America before,
no Syrian that is.
But he must have become enamored
of the country or learned
about the opportunities or thought
he saw an opportunity in America.
They set sail from
Beirut in July of 1878,
stopped off at the Universal
Exposition in Paris on the way,
and they became great
goers to fairs.
They went to every fair that
they could possibly go to.
They loved these world fairs.
World's Fairs the first one they
went to was in Paris and they landed
in New York on August 21st in 1878.
This is a photograph of them in
Beirut just before they set sail.
It's the only known photograph of
Mary, the wife, who's sitting next
to Yosef the father
obviously in the front.
And you will notice that the two
young boys are holding books.
This was a trope that was used
in the Middle East often to show
that they were literate, and the
whole family of course was literate,
even the young boys at that time.
The back of the photograph has
Najeeb's handwriting on the back.
The Smithsonian is not entirely
sure where this came from,
but I think it was actually given
to, probably not the president
of the United States himself, but
one of his staff members when Najeeb
and his father visited
the White House in 1881.
But the picture was taken
earlier before they'd -
before they left Beirut.
When the day they landed,
the Arbeelys' impressed the New
York newspaper reporters like crazy.
They were literate.
They were fluent in English,
at least some of them were.
They clearly understood what they
were about and the newspapers wrote
about them as the first
Syrian immigrant family,
which is what the family
said about themselves.
"We are the first and
we're here to pave the way
for other Syrians to come."
He came without a job, apparently.
And so after a few days the
newspapers started to think
"Oh maybe he's - they're
going to all become a burden
on the city of New York."
Because they're indigent,
they have no money.
A few days after that they decided
that they were secretly rich
and that they had a bank
account in New Jersey.
How they could have set up
a bank account in New Jersey
when they had arrived three
days before is a little bit odd,
but they thought he had a
bank account in New Jersey
and that he was pretending
to be poor in order
to get the American government
or the New York government
to help them.
In fact, it shows to me
the kind of schizophrenia
of Americans toward Syrians,
which began that first week,
because they didn't know
whether they were wonderful,
ready to be assimilated
entrepreneurs
or whether they were
liars, cheats and beggars.
And both the Arbeelys'
were subjected to both.
In any case, he was offered a job
at the Presbyterian College in,
wait for this, Maryville Tennessee,
which he accepted may have been
through his contacts in Beirut.
They all got on the train
and went to Tennessee.
They were a family of nine,
because they arrived in New York
with the six sons, the
parents, and a niece, Jimelee.
And they arrived in Maryville,
Tennessee, nine of them
and the Maryville, Tennessee
had a population of 1100.
So you can imagine
how they stood out,
particularly if they were dressed
as they were in the Beirut picture,
but by the time they got
to Maryville they were
already - they settled in.
The newspapers treated them as if
they were normal Maryville residents
and the two sons opened
their medical practices,
Felala and Abraham.
They were immediately
accepted as doctors
by the Tennessee population,
as just regular doctors.
Clearly the Syrian Protestant
College diploma was all they needed
to set up shop and Felala, in
particular who practice in Maryville
for quite a few years would be
mentioned along with other doctors
as if he were just one
of the Tennessee doctors.
Nothing. They talked about
their comings and goings,
but only in the context of other
people's comings and goings.
They went to Knoxville and spent
the night at such and such a hotel.
Every once in a while they
would say something like
"They're an industrious family."
Or "Very sober."
Or "Very, very good workers."
And they would never say
that about a Tennesseean.
It goes without saying.
So of course they were
seen as different,
but in mainly a positive way.
Joseph's wife, Mary, whom you
see in this picture sitting next
to him died in 1880,
only two years -
less than two years
after they arrived.
She's buried in Maryville,
in the Maryville cemetery.
And she's the only one of
the family, oddly enough,
who has a stone erected to her.
Her children carved a stone for her.
And soon after her death the family
started their peripatetic life.
First, Yosef and his oldest son,
Abraham, went to Texas looking
for a place to establish a
Syrian colony, which they did all
of their lives and they
never found the place -
a place that suited them.
Abraham hung up his medical
shingle in San Antonio, Texas.
Yosef came back to Maryville.
His three youngest sons went
to Maryville High School,
which was part of the
College and then went
to a Quaker School 300
miles from home for college.
And Najeeb, the third youngest went
to law school at Marysville College.
At the same time that
they were doing all
of this educational stuff
they started to travel
around first Eastern
Tennessee, then the east coast
and then the whole
country doing shows.
This is them again in Tennessee
taken right after the death of Mary.
This is what the empty chair is for.
It's a memorial to her.
And Jimelee, the niece
is on the left.
And I just want to show you
this comparative picture,
because the picture on the right
is the only picture that's ever
circulated of the family and it's
been reproduced in many things,
including a [inaudible] book on
this - on Syrian immigration.
And this sign says "I and my
family are enjoying freedom here."
So it was clearly meant as a
photograph to be sent home to Syria.
They wanted the Syrians to
follow them and they wanted
to be the founders of a colony.
So they began to travel
around giving shows, lectures,
and entertainments
about the Holy Land.
Oh I - sorry this is just
the - to show that Najeeb -
the children were in
American schools.
So they went - they began to go
around giving programs
on the Holy Land.
First Yosef went with
one or two of his sons.
They would give a lecture
about the Holy Land.
And the fact that they
were called people
from the Holy Land made it
acceptable and probably uplifting
for people to come to this event.
They charge 25 cents for adults,
15 cents for children under 12,
and according to many of the review
that were done afterwards
every place was packed.
They performed and
you'll see that this one
in particular is interesting.
I'm not sure if you can read it,
because the resolution is not too
great, but it was clearly written
by the Arbeelys' themselves,
and this was a performance
in Wheeling, West Virginia in 1883.
They didn't just lecture
though, and particularly
when the boys were involved and
by this time the boys were already
at least looking like men, even
though they were in their teens.
They dressed up and they
performed as Muslim-whatevers.
So this Najeeb Arbeely on the left
dressed like a Mohammedan Sheikh
and I have it in quotes because this
is what's written in the caption
of the photograph at
the Smithsonian.
On the right probably Najeeb
and Habeeb dressed as women
and you'll see with the
[inaudible] and the [inaudible].
And, you know, wearing those
shoes, smoking a nargile [sp]
or a, you know, and shisha.
This is all in Washington
DC by the way,
which is why the Smithsonian
has it, has these.
Dancing. Playing instruments
with the nargile in the front.
Sword play and again doing
her daily activities.
This is Habeeb dressed up as
a woman and this is Najeeb
and his Sheikh outfit showing
that he's literate again,
writing in a book and with the, you
know, the rugs which they carried
around with them and the cushions.
I'm going to just talk a little
bit now about the family,
because the family had a
very poignant life history,
all of them did.
And it shows you, I think a
little bit about the stress
and sometimes tragedy
that might be inherent
in being the first of anything.
And I'm going to talk to you about
them in the order and I'm sorry
to say this, but in the
order in which they died,
because they all died
young and it was a -
it tells quite a bit
about the family.
So this is the last one
doing the Muslim prayers.
This is an article from
The New York Tribune,
where they use the photographs of
the Arbeelys' to talk about life
in the east and the photographs were
obviously from their performances,
but they took sketches from
them and reproduce them
as if they came directly
from the east.
So the first one I want to talk
about, because he was the first
to die is Felala, who got his
medical degree in 1876 at SPC
and hung up his shingle
and Maryville, Tennessee,
married his cousin Jimelee, in
1885 and moved to Atlanta, Georgia.
He was always looking for a
place for his health and I think
that he had tuberculosis.
They never said what
was wrong with him,
but I think he had tuberculosis.
So he and Jimelee moved to Atlanta
and every summer he would go
to a spa to try and become
the medical doctor there,
but to try to cure his health.
They had two children in
Atlanta and in 1890 he went
to his brother's home in
Los Angeles and died there.
His brother Abraham,
reported this that he would -
"Even when he was dying he was
interested from a standpoint
of reason in the very feelings
and alterations which were wrought
by the dissolution of his body."
He was buried under the
auspices of the Royal Arcanum,
which is a fraternal - secret
fraternal organization,
which paid death duties to widows
and families of people who died
who were members of the
Arcanum and he was buried
in an unmarked grave in Los Angeles.
And then when his father died a
few years later they were buried
together in the unmarked grave
in Los Angeles and then moved
to an unmarked grave in
Monrovia, California.
And why they were unmarked you
can speculate as well as I can
about why they were unmarked.
This is Yosef with
Abraham, the oldest son.
Yosef is clearly on the right.
Even after settling in Monrovia,
California, which he did in 1886,
he traveled all over California
giving lectures on the Holy Land.
You see his name in Oakland
newspapers, San Francisco newspapers
in Riverside, in Redlands, in Los
Angeles County, in Redondo Beach.
He was everywhere giving lectures
pretty much until the day he died.
He died in 1890, as I said in
Monrovia, was buried with his son
and then they were
moved to Monrovia.
His will is accent and he had
a rather - he was 66 years old.
He had a rather substantial estate
including Romalian railroad bonds.
Does anyone here know
where Romalia was?
I did not.
It's what's - it's part of
what's now Southern Bulgaria,
but it was part of
the Ottoman Empire.
He had Romalian railroad bonds, a
stock in the New Jersey Railroad
and Canal Company, two vineyards
in Amioun, Lebanon an olive orchard
in Erbil, his natal village, a
library of 30 books valued at $20
by the appraiser, a gold bracelet
which he left his only granddaughter
and $6,000 in cash was quite an
estate in 1890, quite an estate.
But he was buried in an
unmarked grave, strangely.
After Joseph's death all
of the surviving brothers,
this is him with his
three grandchildren
that existed at that time.
And it was taken in
San Francisco, 1891.
After Joseph's death all
of the surviving brothers
met briefly in New York.
Three of them made
their will at that time.
I don't know why.
Two of them, Naceem and Habeeb, the
two youngest moved to Cairo, Egypt.
Habeeb died six months
after they arrived.
He had an estate worth $2,000,
which was substantial and he left it
in sole, as sole legatee
his brother Naceem.
He was mourned even in the obituary
on the right is a New
Orleans newspaper.
He was mourned in the New
Orleans newspaper by a friend
who lived there, Baton Rouge,
but also in New Orleans.
But he was - and he was buried in
the Orthodox cemetery in Cairo.
Kaleel, who is the second
son who never went to SPC.
We don't know.
I don't think he ever
went to college anywhere.
He may not have finished
secondary school.
I think he was the only one of the
sons who was not fluent in English
and may have been illiterate.
His will was written
by someone else.
He set up briefly in Los Angeles
in the 1880s as a pharmacist.
We don't know if he had a
pharmaceutical degree from anywhere,
because there's no record
of it that I could find.
And then he moved east to New York.
He lived in a tenement in Brooklyn
by himself a few blocks away
from his brother but
not with his brother
and he died alone of tuberculosis.
He had an estate worth
less than $800.
He left it to his brothers,
leaving Najeeb,
his near neighbor out of the will.
And you have to ask why?
And he did it deliberately.
He wrote in his will, "I'm leaving
nothing to my brother Najeeb."
And we don't know why.
There must have been
bad blood between them.
Naceem, who's the youngest, I'm
doing this a little bit out of order
because his death came
a little later,
but I want to get him
out of the way.
Who went to Cairo with his brother
set up a dental practice there.
He had gotten the dental degree,
but hadn't practiced before.
He had been in the import, export
business in New York for many years.
He lived there, apparently without
marrying and without having a family
by himself until his death in 1919
about two weeks before
his eldest brother.
He died in Cairo.
He had an estate worth $900,
which was completely
consumed by creditors.
So he had nothing to
leave when he died.
And on the right of
this picture is Najeeb.
It's the only picture except for
those group pictures we have of him.
He must have been camera shy.
We don't know why there
were no pictures of him.
Najeeb had an incredible
beginning to his career.
He was named Consul
General to Jerusalem
by President Cleveland in 1885.
For a new immigrant and for
someone who was only 25 years old,
he had just turned
25 when he was named.
It was quite incredible.
And we don't know how Cleveland knew
of him, found him, recognized him.
We have no idea, unless he saw him
in a performance in Washington DC
at some point and Najeeb was in
the White House a couple of times,
but whether he ever met
the president I don't know.
So he went to Jerusalem.
He bought his uniform
and he went to Jerusalem.
But he was - they were - the
Ottoman Government refused
to accept his credentials and
the reason they refused was
because the Ottoman government
considered every Ottoman citizen an
Ottoman citizen.
And you could not, not
be an Ottoman citizen.
And so how could an Ottoman
citizen represent the United States
and the consulate in Jerusalem.
So he was sent home after
seven months, but always went
by the honorific X Consul General.
[ Laughs ]
>> Always.
They always called him that.
He called himself that and
people called him that.
After his return in 1886 he and his
brother Naceem were in the import,
export business and in 1892 he
and his older brother Abraham
did the most groundbreaking thing
in the world, they founded the
first Arabic language newspaper
in the United States.
And as far as I know, maybe
someone from the Library
of Congress can tell
me that I'm wrong.
This is the only extant issue
of the newspaper that exists.
There are four years on microfilm
Library of Congress has it.
[inaudible] University in Beirut
has a copy of the four years
on microfilm, but this is
the only actual paper copy
that exists as far as I know.
The microfilm came from the
Universe of Kansas Public Library
and they got rid of all of
their original newspapers many,
many years ago.
So and this came from the
Arbeely family in Texas.
It's incredible to have it.
It was published in Arabic with
one page of English for one year.
I find this hysterical because who
- what English speaker would want
to read about the little
Syrian colony.
I can't imagine who their audience,
who they thought their audience
would be, but if you read all
of the English language
part for the year
that it was published they
were preaching to the Americans
about what great people they were
and about what peace
loving people they were.
But clearly.
no American was reading this.
So after a year it
became exclusively Arabic.
They set up shop at 45 Pearl
Street in Lower Manhattan about six
or eight blocks from
the Syrian colony.
They had - the two brothers
lived there, when Abraham was
in town Najeeb, who lived in New
York in the loft at 45 Pearl Street,
the third brother Naceem,
when he was in town.
They had three employees, the
compositor and two Arabic editors.
And all six of them lived in this
three room loft in Pearl Street.
They all slept there.
There was a little kitchen that
they cooked for each other and then
in the daytime they covered all
the beds with oriental carpets.
They hung daggers on the wall.
They had a parrot because they
thought that was very Oriental
to have a parrot and lots of palm
tree plants and that kind of thing.
And so when people would come to
see the office they would espouse,
talk about how Oriental
the place was
and how they were living
this fantasy Oriental life
when in fact they knew exactly,
the Arbeelys' knew exactly
what they were doing.
The paper had a dual audience,
at least a dual Arabic audience.
The Syrians in the Diaspora, because
it was founded in 1892 by that time,
there were probably 900 Syrians in
New York and there were Syrians all
over the United States
in almost every state
and territory by that time.
They have - so the Syrian
Diaspora was their audience,
but also Syrians at home.
And there was a story and
I don't know if it was true
and I'm sure Najeeb told the
story to the American newspapers
that the Sultan himself received a
copy of the newspaper on parchment
with gold, with gilt
ornaments on it.
We don't know if that's true or not.
They claimed a circulation
of 50,000,
which was an exaggeration
by about 49,000 I think.
[ Laughs ]
But they had readers, they did have
readers all over the United States
and they had readers and agents in
South America, in the Middle East
and many cities in the Middle
East and even in Europe as well.
So it was read by the
Syrian Diaspora
in many places and Syrians at home.
And it was - it kind of
embodied the dilemma that Syrians
in the Diaspora were feeling.
On the one hand it was
very assimilationist.
They talked about how
to become successful
as an American businessman.
They talked about how to adjust
to American ways of doing things.
They advocated for a school
for their children to go
to that was part of the New
York Public School system rather
than having to set
up their own schools.
At the same time they
cautioned people
and at the same time they
cautioned Syrians to act well
so that the Americans had nothing
to criticize the Syrian colony for.
But at the same token
they complained like crazy
about the bad morals of Americans,
about how they didn't want their
women's honor sullied by the way
that women acted in
the United States,
that American business men
were so tricky and dishonest
and they didn't want to
ever become like that.
So Najeeb and Abraham would write
editorials giving advice to people
in the United States saying
"Your honor is worth everything
and you must maintain your honor."
And "The almighty dollar is not
what you should be going after."
Najeeb did many other things
besides run the newspaper.
He was an interpreter
at Ellis Island,
a full time interpreter
at Ellis Island.
He made a $1,000 year doing
that, which was a good salary.
He also continued to buy
and sell Syrian goods.
He took out concessions at
every single World's Fair
and then would rent out
booths to other Syrians.
He continued to perform.
There's a marvelous article
in 1894 that he wrote himself
where he assembled a troop
of 100 Syrians to perform
for the Shriners in Madison Square.
You know who the Shriners
are, right?
Those guys who wear those fezzes.
And here's what Najeeb said.
He wrote that "Red
fezzes were as perplexing
to the Orientals on the platform."
That is the Syrians, "As the
costumes of these were interesting
and novel to those whom they faced."
And you can imagine the Syrian
troop looking at these 15,000 men
with their fezzes applauding
them and they performed
as howling Dervishes, the Syrians,
you can imagine howling Dervishes.
Yeah, it's quite marvelous.
And Najeeb was ubiquitous.
He was always giving interviews.
He was friends with the
editors of The Herald Tribune.
New York World editors
and he was always being interviewed
anytime anyone had a question
about the New York Syrian
colony he was the one they asked
for an opinion.
He was ready to opine about
anything, but that picture
that I show you is the only one.
That was his memorial card.
It's the only one that
I've ever seen of him.
He suffered a stroke in 1900.
He had to give up both the newspaper
and his job at Ellis Island.
And he decided to go back
to his original career,
which was being a lawyer, which
he had studied in Maryville.
And so he passed the New York
bar with no problem whatsoever.
And on his way to the office,
they say the first day on his way
to the office he suffered a second
stroke and he died in Manhattan.
He was 43 years old.
The newspaper already under new
management folded a few years
after that out.
He died without a will
and his widow claimed
that his estate was
worth less than $200.
He left a widow and six
children under the age of eleven.
One of whom was born seven
months after he died.
So. And his widow went to work
as a matron in Ellis Island,
essentially took his
place at Ellis Island,
but not really as an interpreter.
She only could deal with the women
and raised her six
children by herself.
Abraham, although the
eldest, lived the longest.
He was the most restless
of the Arbeelys'.
He lived in practice in Austin,
Texas, Hot Springs, Arkansas,
Washington DC, Los
Angeles, New York,
Cairo and ended his days
in Washington DC again.
He bought and sold real
estate in Los Angeles.
He was really early pioneer real
estate speculator in Los Angeles
because his wife's family were
pioneer Los Angeles families
and they were big and
wealthy ranchers
in Los Angeles in the
1860s and 1870s.
He and his wife came in the 1880s
who set up a medical practice
and he did real estate
speculation, did extremely well.
He wrote a gigantic
Arabic English primer,
which when put together
was 850 pages.
He sold it and [inaudible] through
subscription, through the newspaper,
through Calcutta of America.
And it went through three printings.
And you can still buy it.
You can buy it on A Books.
There are a couple of
copies available on A Books.
He sold antiquities to
the Smithsonian Museum.
He continued to write
albeit articles
for various Arabic newspapers
until his death in 1919.
He was the only member of the
family to live his full threescore
and ten years and he had
outlived all of his brothers,
and of course his parents.
The dilemmas that beset other
immigrants about assimilation,
success, honor, culture and raising
children in a Strange Land seemed
to have skipped the Arbeelys'.
For one thing they had always
planned to stay in America
and they did their utmost
to take advantage of all
that America had to offer.
On the first day that Yosef and the
family arrived in New York he said
"I want my children educated here
and I want them to marry here."
Three of the sons were educated in
the United States and three married
and had families in America,
just as their father had wished.
Two of them married to what
the Syrians call Americans,
although they weren't really.
They were just non-Syrians
and the third one Felala married his
cousin Jimelee who came with them.
But all of their children, so the
six of Najeeb, the five of Abraham
and the two of Felala
all married Americans.
Not one of them married another
Syrian or another Arab of any kind.
More importantly from my
point of view as, you know,
as a 19th ethnography,
they paved the way
for what became a very respectable
way of making a living for all
of the Syrians, which was
entertaining on the stage
and in church halls and in YMCAs,
all over the United States,
giving lectures, dressing
up as Muslims,
doing reenactment of
Muslim weddings.
And they made it respectable.
Vaudeville for other peoples had
a kind of unsavory reputation,
but for the Syrians it was no
different than running a store
or being a paddler or having a
warehouse or a wholesale business
and the Arbeelys' constructed
this life of entertaining
and re-enacting Middle
Eastern rites and rituals
and made it okay for everyone else.
They seem to have constructed
and deftly manage the two halves
of their identity, the
American and the other,
succeeding in both worlds while
keeping them completely separate.
If one can detect cracks in their
smooth presentation of self,
they're perhaps to be found in
their restlessness and effort
to find a place where they
might really fit, perhaps,
in the return of two of the
brothers to the Middle East but not
to Damascus or Beirut, but to Cairo.
And in the illnesses
which plague the family
and cause the premature death
of five of the six brothers.
And that they ended up
living and dying so far
from each other may
indicate family strife.
So being first was a
double edged sword.
They were able to forge their own
identity with few to criticize them,
no role models and they
were truly on their own.
And they made it up
as they went along.
Not just because in the first years
of their sojourn there were no
other Syrians in the United States
for them to be with, but the
fact that they, as a family,
seemed to live far away from other
Syrians even when Syrians came.
The - you can see that Najeeb set
up the business six blocks
from the Syrian colony.
It doesn't sound a lot today
but in those days it was a lot.
It meant that they were separated
and then you had people in DC,
you had people in Los Angeles,
you had people in Atlanta, Georgia
and two men who went back to Cairo,
two brothers who went back to Cairo.
So they really didn't
seem to be much part
of the Syrian colony even
though they published the Syrian
Colony Newspaper.
Whatever their difficulties
may have been the Arbeelys',
it must be said succeeded.
Not financially because none
was ever rich, but in figuring
out how an Arab might successfully
assimilate while keeping hold
of his albeit Orientalized culture.
We owe them a great deal.
Thank you.
[ Clapping ]
So if there are questions I probably
have to have Muhannad translate
for me because I'm hard of hearing
but I'm happy to answer anything
and that I'm happy to sign books.
>> Woman: I'm curious
figure how the [inaudible]?
>> Muhannad Salhi: The
question is, she would like to,
you'd like to know
how the family fit
into racial categories,
especially in the South.
>> Joan Weeks: Okay.
So they were considered white.
They were always considered white,
all Syrians were considered white
until the '20s when people
began to worry about that
for citizenship purposes
and there were some - well,
the first citizenship trial with
the Syrians was in 1909 actually,
but that hinged on
whether they were white.
However you define -
however they defined white,
but in the nineteenth century, no.
And in every census form
they're always white,
always considered to be white.
So there was no problem and really
it's kind of astonishing to me.
They had really good friends
in Tennessee called the McTeers
and there was once a critical
article written about one
of their performances and Mr.
McTeer wrote an angry letter
to the newspaper defending them
and saying not only was
the performance authentic,
but the family was a fantastic
family and that people should get
to know them because
they were wonderful.
So they were really, to me,
amazingly quickly accepted
in Tennessee.
Further questions?
>> Man: I'm curious
about two things.
I'm assuming that this first wave
[inaudible] Christian, and...
>> Joan Weeks: I heard that
one but I'll repeat it.
Yeah.
>> Man: And the other thing that
is curious is this is the time
when the nation [inaudible]
and therefore I assume your
[inaudible] the word Oriental,
that is what in Arabic
[inaudible] Eastern as well
because I don't think
[inaudible] necessary identifying
as Syrian specifically or
Lebanese or et cetera, et cetera.
At this period I think the
identity was basically what?
I'm curious.
>> Muhannad Salhi: How did that...
>> Joan Weeks: Okay,
you're going to have
to say it again because
I didn't hear.
I'm sorry.
>> Muhannad Salhi: Basically how
did the identify as Orientals,
as Syrians, as - generally speaking
how would they have identified?
>> Joan Weeks: So they
identified as Ottoman.
Well, let me answer your first
question first about the Christians.
Yes, 95% of the 19th century
immigrants were Christians.
There were some Muslims.
They didn't go to New York ever.
They went and homesteaded
in the West.
So you find early Muslims in
Texas, in North Dakota, in Ohio,
which was the west then a
bit, in Idaho, in Montana,
but there were Muslims in New
York, but they weren't Syrians,
they were students at Columbia
and they were Turks mainly.
And by 1910 that was beginning to
change, because there were beginning
to be Syrian Muslims coming.
So, yes, but they were
Syrians, but of all four sects.
These guys were Orthodox, but
the Maronites, the Melkites,
Presbyterians and Orthodox
were all well represented
in the very first influx of Syrians.
So how did they identify themselves?
Well they - if you're talking about
the Arbeelys' themselves I think,
in fact, that they
joined Quaker meeting.
I think they became
Quakers when they came.
I know that Habeeb and Naceem
were Quakers or considered
to be Quakers by the Quaker meeting.
And only had their name struck
off long after they died.
Yosef performed, gave lectures
at Quaker meetings in Maine
and in Tennessee and when
they went to the White House
in 1881 they were accompanied
by a Quaker minister.
So I actually think
that they were Quakers
and I thought maybe
the whole family was.
But I don't have any
other evidence for that.
But they were Orthodox,
Orthodox, Orthodox,
and they consider themselves
to be Ottoman, everyone did.
And they would call each
other sons of Ottoman.
>> Man: In other words,
was Syria ever used?
Syrians?
>> Joan Weeks: Syrians were used.
Yes. So for example at the 1893 fair
the [inaudible] published a list
of Syrian merchants who
were selling at the fair
and they were called
Syrian merchants.
They wanted to distinguish them
from the Ottoman concession,
which was separate even though
it was also run by Syrians.
>> Man: And at this time did
Syria also include [inaudible]?
>>
>> Muhannad Salhi: Yes,
it was Greater Syria.
>> Joan Weeks: It was Greater Syria.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
[ Inaudible ]
>> Joan Weeks: Yes.
And they call [inaudible] who was
one of the two Syrian Jews who were
in New York at that time was in
that list of Syrians who were
at the fair, because he was
considered to be the same category
as the Syrian Christians.
Yeah, yeah.
Any other questions?
>> Muhannad Salhi: I
actually have a question.
>> Joan Weeks: Yeah, please.
>> Muhannad Salhi: You
mentioned that these are the -
this is the first Syrian family
in the United States and -
but at one point there
were more Syrians
or more Arabs coming to [inaudible].
Do we have any documents about this
steady influx of Syrians or Arabs?
>> Joan Weeks: Oh yeah.
Oh yes. I mean that's
really what my book is
about for the first 20 years.
I mean, yes there's all
sorts of documentation.
As you all probably know the
1890 census does not exist.
It burned in a fire.
The federal census, and
so that is the - for us,
for the Syrians it would
have been a crucial census,
because that would have
been the biggest influx.
1880 census has a few people on it,
but the 1890 census would have
been the key census for us.
And it does not exist.
So it's a big lack in our
knowledge of the influx of Syrians,
but there are summary
reports of the 1890 census.
So you can get a sense of
the, at least the numbers.
They came in the 1880s in a trickle.
In the 1890s, especially with the
Chicago fair caused this huge influx
and HH Jessup, who's a Presbyterian
minister in Lebanon from the 1860s
on laments the fact that the
town of Saali lost 300 young men
in one week, all of whom were
coming to the Chicago fair.
And that was probably a third
of the male population
of Saali at that time.
So it was a huge attraction for
people to come to the Chicago Fair
in 1893 and a lot of
those people stayed.
They stayed.
So that was the biggest
pull to come.
Yeah.
>> Man: You use the word Syrian
Diaspora, can you elaborate on that?
>> Muhannad Salhi: You use
the word Syrian Diaspora.
Can you elaborate on that?
>> Joan Weeks: Yeah.
So the Syrians didn't just
come to the United States.
Of course they went everywhere.
There are many, many, many Syrians
in South America, in Brazil,
as you know because
some of the presidents
of these countries have
Syrian names, right?
They came to South America.
There was lots of business going
on in Mexico, in Mexico City
and in the Yucatan and [inaudible].
In the Caribbean, there was a big
Syrian colony in Cuba, one in Haiti,
one in Jamaica, one in the
Dominican Republic and of course
in all the states of the
Union, all the territories.
I have evidence of Syrians in Hawaii
in 1905 buying and selling property.
And then, you know, of course
there were Syrians in Manchester,
England starting in the 1860s.
In France, the Maronites were going
to France early this
year and West Africa.
They were everywhere.
>> Man: Why did they leave?
>> Muhannad Salhi:
Why did they leave?
>> Joan Weeks: Good question.
So everyone debates this
and the Syrians have their
own story about why they left.
The Syrians always told the
same story, which I just love
because it's the same story
that Yosef Arbeely told
on the first day he got there.
"Oh. we were oppressed by the
Muslim overlords and we came
to bask in American freedom."
Well, maybe, but probably not.
Probably they came because
there was an opportunity
and that's what Yosef saw.
He saw - he called it gold fever
and people came, the silk industry
in Mount Lebanon collapsed
in the 1880s.
That had - and they had converted
all of their farms to silkworms,
so they were no longer
growing food for themselves.
So they had silkworms, the
silk industry collapsed
and they had no income.
So it got really, really hard for
them and there was - there were lots
of famines going on in Mount
Lebanon in the 1880s and 1890s.
And there was this
country beckoning.
There were no visas.
So people came.
>> Man: Did a lot of them leave
because of the Ottoman draft?
>> Muhannad Salhi: Did a lot of them
leave because of the Ottoman draft?
>> Joan Weeks: That was later.
Yeah, that was in 1909.
It was later.
Yeah. Some certainly did.
Some certainly did.
But the big influx was
really from 1890 to 1910.
And the people stayed
until the First World War.
So there were, you know, by about
1911 there were 9,000 Syrians coming
every year to New York.
So - to the United
States I should say,
most of the landing in New York.
And some of that has
to do with the draft.
My grandfather - my grandmother
and grandfather went back to Syria
to visit in 1914 and my
grandfather made a run
for the American consulate in
Beirut to prove, to get a letter
from the American consul that
he was an American citizen,
so he would not be drafted.
Because the Ottoman still
considered him an ottoman citizen
and he wanted the consul to
say, essentially will fight
for you if you get drafted.
Yeah. So. Okay well thank you.
>> Muhannad Salhi:
Thank you very much.
>> Joan Weeks: Thank
you so much for coming.
[ Clapping ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.